oh a rare piece of good news a federal
judge has struck down the insane mask
mandate on planes and trains the much
beleaguered passenger class in this
country celebrated upon hearing the news
watch this
masks are no longer required on domestic
flights or U.S airports while employees
and customers are no longer required to
wear a mask they may do so if they
choose
[Music]
[Applause]
passengers
yeah
we moved the mask mandate
[Music]
and enjoy and celebrate
so the mass mandate never made sense on
planes the Aeron planes is filtered it's
way safer than a restaurant the whole
point of the Mandate was to humiliate
you and get you to obey and people hated
it and the airlines knew they hated it
so almost every major carrier in the
country lifted the mandates as soon as
the judge allowed them to
but Joe Biden's publicist was a
dedicated enemy of human happiness and
really ought to be teaching in a
kindergarten classroom in New York City
said she's disappointed in the judge's
ruling watch
CDC recommended continuing the order for
additional time two weeks to be able to
assess the latest science in keeping
with its responsibility to protect the
American people so this is obviously a
disappointing decision
No One Believes you anymore No One
Believes the CDC anymore you drained
your credibility account over the last
year by lying to us you're a joke you're
the only ones who don't know it and they
don't know it a couple of hours ago the
bite Administration announced it will
appeal the ruling if the CDC tells them
to quote if the CDC concludes a
mandatory order remains necessary the
doj will appeal the doj
nobody wants that the only people who
are in favor of it are the journalists
who work for the administration which is
virtually all of them and they're
thrilled at the possibility that the
American population will once again be
subjugated because they deserve it watch
what do we need to know about this
ruling are we kind of in the Wild West
it's every company for itself
100 it's a it's a mess just because this
ruling was made by a judge doesn't mean
that suddenly the science has changed we
meant we know that masks remain very
protective and this was basically Donald
Trump as a federal judge today
yeah yeah it absolutely reads like
Donald Trump as a federal judge so what
we've done is we've removed a travel
mask mandate uh with an incredibly high
level of virus and right now as of today
it is less safe to fly in this country
than it was yesterday she obvious ly
obviously is clue
saved millions of lives
Masters and millions of wives and some
low IQ politician who's never had a job
she knows the science
Candace Owens knows a lot more about
science than the lady you just heard
she's the founder of blacks that we're
always happy to have her on it's just
it's so unbelief their powers ebbing
away and they're mad hmm
what we're looking at these people
Tucker they're just they're sick these
are utterly sick mentally unstable
people who want people to suffer out of
sport out of sheer sport we obviously
know the science does not make sense it
never makes sense talk about science
ever shipping that's exactly what the
CDC specializes in making up things like
you as they go along like like they are
actually Simon says in the child's game
and you know what it is sad to me to see
so many flight attendants celebrating
and people that are in the seats because
you realize people have just been
suffering fearful they're going to go to
prison the first announcement they hear
if you don't comply you know you can be
arrested imagine having a federal charge
because you didn't wear a mask over your
face we watch children suffer we watch
special needs kids get kicked off of
planes for their inability to keep their
mouths on to keep their masks on their
face as well as young kids as two years
old crying and screaming not
understanding why they're being made to
wear a mask and this is really just
happening in America by the way I've
traveled all across Europe they've all
released the mass manage this is not
based in science this is just based in
control the government took power they
don't want to give it back and to me as
happy as I am as relieved as I am that I
can go on a plane and not wear a mask I
don't feel like this is a win because we
shouldn't be cheering on the restoration
of our basic human rights we should be
infuriated and we should want to see
these people face consequences because
guess what Tucker the CDC broke the law
that's the ruling says it was
unconstitutional similarly OSHA broke
the law they were trying to overreach
and decide if they could do things that
they had entirely no powers to do so
when regular people break the law Tucker
they go to prison why is Rachel wolensky
in the CDC and the members of the FDA
and the drug cartel that's operating our
country any exception to that rule it's
unacceptable and I'm not going to cheer
until these people are behind bars what
they have done to the Dignity of human
beings forcing them to sit behind maps
that we know do not work to stop the
spread of the virus
now I would say maybe Candace Owens has
overstating the case and then I see that
life expectancy for American citizens is
down due to their mismanagement of covet
not from covet but due to their
regulations and I think you know maybe
you're right over the Target and so I
appreciate it Candace Owens thank you
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight